[Music]
apigee x allows you to expose your apis
to end users by implementing api proxies
away proxies are nothing but a wrapper
for your actual apis
did you know that the api proxy must be
deployed for it to be invoked
the process of deploying the ebay proxy
and making it accessible to the end
users is referred to as api proxy
deployment before you deploy your api
proxy you need to complete a set of
prerequisites correctly
networking and routing configurations
are two of the key prerequisites for api
proxy deployment
a key point to note if the
configurations are not defined correctly
then your api proxies may not be
accessible
in this video we will learn the apigee x
networking architecture and demonstrate
how to verify the networking
configuration of an apigee x
organization on high level there are
three key things to be configured in
networking
first the virtual private clouds ovpcs
apigex instances are provisioned in
internal google managed vpcs
however google managed vpcs are not
directly accessible from your gcp
projects
therefore you need to pair them either
with vpcs or shared vpcs created in your
gcp projects
secondly the manage instance group omig
currently gcp load balances cannot
directly route requests to google manage
vpcs
therefore you need to use a mig for 14
requests received by the load balancer
to the apigee x instance
be aware that this mig needs to be
created in the same vpc network attached
to the apigee ex organization and an
ingress firewall rule is required for
allowing the load balancer to route
request to the mig
finally the load balancer
depending on your routing requirements
you could either choose an external or
an internal load balancer for routing
requests to the apigee x instances
keep in mind that if you are using a
shared vpc then ensure that all manage
instance groups client hos and target
hosts are created in the same network as
shown in this diagram
alright
let's jump into the google cloud console
and verify the networking configuration
in a sample apigee x organization
first off let's verify if the proper vpc
network is attached to a sample apigee x
organization
open the cloud shell
execute the following api request to
determine the vpc network attached to
the apigex organization
the authorized network property in this
output refers to the name of the
attached vpc
if you are using a shared vpc ensure
that authorized network property has the
name of the actual vpc that is attached
to the gcp project in which the load
balancer and the mig's are created
next up to verify the configuration of
the mig
go to compute engine instance groups
page and select your mig
click on the instance template scroll
down to the network tags section and
note down the tags
next
ensure the vpc network defined in the
network interfaces section is the same
as the vpc attached to the apigee x
organization
scroll down further to the custom
metadata section and verify the endpoint
ip address against the apigee x instance
ip address
navigate to the vpc network firewall
page and verify the ingress firewall
rule
be aware this firewall rule needs to be
created in the same vpc attached to the
apigee x organization
ensure that the network tags of the mig
are defined under target tags
and allow the load balancer healthcheck
probes source ip addresses ranges are
included under the source filters
section
finally let's look at how to verify the
load balancer configuration
go to network services load balancing
and click on the load balancer name
under the front end section verify that
protocol ip address port and the tls
certificate are configured correctly
next if any host and path rules are
defined verify whether they are
configured correctly
lastly under the backline section verify
that the load balancer backend is
healthy and it is pointing to the right
mig which forwards traffic to the apogex
instance to summarize you learn the
networking architecture in apigee x and
how to verify the networking
configuration
namely vpc mig and load balancers are
configured correctly in an apigee ex
organization
[Music]